let's say i have two intersecting line
segments so let's call that l
that's segment a
b
and then i have a segment
and then i have segment c d
so that is c
and that is d and they intersect right
over here at point e
and let's say we know we're given that
this angle right over here that the
measure of angle let me that b is kind
of i don't know why i wrote it so far
away so let me make that a little bit
closer let me make that b a little bit
closer
so let's say we do that in yellow
let's say that we know
let's say that we know that the measure
of this angle right over here angle b e
d let's say that we know that that
measure is 70 degrees
given that information what i want to do
based only on what we know so far not
using a protractor what i want to do is
figure out what the other angles in this
picture are so what's the measure of
angle c e b the measure of angle a e c
and the measure of angle a e d
so the first thing that you might notice
when you look at this i've already told
you that this is a line segment and this
is a line segment you see that
you see that angle b
e
d
and angle c e b
are adjacent
they are adjacent
and we also see that if you take the
outer sides of those angles it forms a
straight angle and we also see that
angle
c e d is a straight angle c e d is a
straight angle
straight angle so we know we know that
these two angles must also be
supplementary they're next to each other
and they form a straight angle when you
take their outer sides so you know
we know that angle bed
angle bed and angle ceb
are supplementary which means they add
up to or that their measures add up to
180 degrees supplement
supplementary
supplementary angles which means
which means which tells us that the
measure of angle bed
plus the measure of angle ceb and i keep
writing measure here sometimes you'll
just see people write angle bed plus
angle ceb is equal to 180 degrees now we
already know the measure of angle bed is
70 degrees so we already know that this
thing right over here is 70 degrees and
so 70 degrees plus the measure of angle
ceb is 180 degrees you subtract 70 from
both sides and we get the measure of
angle c e b
is equal to
108 degrees i just subtracted 70 from
both sides of that so we figured out
that this right over here
is
110 degrees well that's interesting and
i went through more steps than you would
if you were doing this problem quickly
if you did this problem quickly in your
head you say look this is 70 degrees
this angle plus this angle would be 180
degrees so this has to be 110 degrees so
now let's use the same logic to figure
out what angle
cea is so now we we care about the
measure of angle c
e
a
and we can use the exact same logic that
we used over here angle c e a and angle
c e b
they form they are adjacent they form a
straight angle if you look at their
outsides so they must be supplementary
they form a straight angle right over
here so they're supplementary so they
must add up to 180 degrees so measure of
angle cea plus the measure of angle ceb
which is 110 degrees must be equal to
180 degrees so once again subtract 110
from both sides you get the measure of
angle c
e a
is equal to
is equal to 70 degrees so this one right
over here is also 70 degrees and what
we'll learn in the next video is that
this is no coincidence these two angles
angle c e a and angle b e d sometimes
they're called opposite angle well i i
i've often called them opposite angles
but the the more correct term for them
is vertical angles and we'll we haven't
proved it we've just seen a special case
here where these vertical angles are
equal but it actually turns out that
vertical angles are always equal but we
haven't proved it to ourselves for the
general case but let me just write down
this word since it's a nice new word so
angle
c e a
and angle b e d and angle b e d angle
bed are vertical
are vertical
and you might say wait they look like
they're horizontal they're next to each
other and the vertical really just means
that they're across from each other
across an intersection from each other
angle c e b and angle aed are also
vertical so let me write that down angle
c
e b
and angle aed
angle a e d are also are also vertical
and that might may even make a little
bit more sense because it literally is
one is on top and one is on bottom
they're kind of vertically opposite from
each other but so are these these
horizontally opposite angles are also
called vertical angles so now we have
one angle left to figure out angle aed
angle aed and based on what i already
told you vertical angles tend to be or
they are always equal you this was
probably we haven't proven that to
ourselves yet so we can't just use that
property to say that this is 110 degrees
so we're going to do is use the exact
same logic c e a and a e d are clearly
supplementary their outsides form a
straight angle they're clearly
supplementary so c e a and a e d must
add up to 180 degrees or we could say
the measure of angle aed
plus the measure
plus the measure of angle c e a
must be equal to 180 degrees we know the
measure of cea is
is 70 degrees
we know it is 70 degrees so you subtract
70 from both sides you get the measure
of angle a
ed is equal to 110 degrees so we got the
exact result
that we expected so this angle right
over here is 110 degrees and so if you
take any of the adjacent angles that
their outside outer sides form a
straight angle you see they add up to
180 this one and that one add up to 180
this one and that one add up to 180 this
one and that one add up to 180 and this
one and that one add up to 180. if you
go all the way around the circle you'll
see that they add up to 360 degrees
because you literally are going all the
way around
so 70 plus 110 is 180 plus 70 is 250
plus 110 is
360 degrees i'll leave you there this is
the first time that we've kind of found
some interesting results using the the
tool kit that we've built up so far and
the next video will actually prove to
ourselves using pretty much the exact
same logic here but we'll just do it
with generalized numbers we won't use 70
degrees to prove that vertical length
that vertical angles that the measure of
vertical angles are equal